- Tonight is a very special night.
There's a little event coming up called the All-Star game.
Now there is something that has been missing.
The All-Star draft.
We are bringing it back from the dead.
And today we have a very special guest.
It is Biz Nasty.
Biz, Where ya at?
What're you up to here, buddy?
- Don't worry about where I am, buddy.
You seem a little bit nervous off that intro.
You OK? What's your heart rate at?
About 180 beats per minute?
- That was smooth!
No stumbling over the words. I'm dressed nice.
You just showed up with a cowboy hat on, all right.
- I'm going Bill Belichick style here,
OK?
I'm also, I'm gonna be all serious, but very laid back.
Like he was at the draft with the, with the
dog at the house at the, at the dinner table.
- OK,
I like that.
So let me run you through the rules real quick.
We're gonna do a 10-player draft with
all of the choices of the players available.
You can sort that however you want.
If you don't wanna have any defenders on your team, you don't need them.
Sound good?
- That sounds great,
I like those rules. Now, how are we gonna decide who goes first?
- Uh, I have a deck of cards.
Do you have a deck of cards, as well?
- I have a deck of cards.
- You do have a deck of cards.
- And I have,
and I have a stopwatch because there's a time limit on this.
I'm gonna put your mind in a pretzel all night long on the draft board here.
So let's— what are we doing?
Drawing highest card for who gets the first pick?
- Let's see a legit, I want to see an actual bridge shuffle going down.
OK.
Yes.
I like this.
I will do the same.
- Here, I'll even close my laptop and close my eyes for you,
OK?
Cuz you probably think I'm cheating.
- Highest card wins here, all right?
Three, two, one. I got a two.
- Oh! Good start for Bizzy Boy!
- I think we're ready to go.
- OK.
- You wanna get us started here?
I'll, uh, I'll put 30 seconds on the clock.
I don't know if you're gonna take that long here
for Pick One, but we'll see what you have in store.
- We already have a jersey made for this guy.
We got Andrei Vasilevskiy, OK?
The foundation to any great team is in goal.
And you look at the last two playoff runs they had, back-to-back championships,
he didn't lose back-to-back games one time on the way to two Stanley cups.
So he's a bread winner, and he's gonna be the foundation to our team.
Welcome to the squad, Vasilevskiy.
I'm just gonna stick with his last name here and keep it really simple.
I think everybody gets the point.
Maybe shorten it, put just Vasy on there.
Just so you get the spelling correct.
And another thing too, a little fun fact for you,
people at home, I was not maybe the biggest cat person.
And then I got to sit down with Vasilevskiy at, uh, the NHL
media scrums in Chicago one year before the season started.
And he actually got me to, uh, to start liking cats.
So the guy has a tons of power and tons of influence, and he's gonna
have a ton of influence in that locker room on winning some games.
- I liked that Biz.
I like that.
All right, my first pick, you know, this is a tough one, right?
Uh, I, I think my goal for this draft is just
to not get chirped too hard on the internet.
So you took Vasy No. 1, which is maybe a bit questionable.
I think you, you will maybe get some hate for that.
I'm gonna go ahead and take the man, the guy that's gonna
go through four guys on the ice when there's only three
out there, Connor McDavid at, uh, at my first overall pick.
- [Snoring sound] With all the drama they got going on right now.
I don't want those types of headaches in my locker room to be quite frank.
I don't want their, their media following my team, getting, giving harassing
questions in the media scrums, if by chance they lose a three-on-three match.
So, I mean, I'd say easily a rookie mistake in your first All-Star selection.
There, Nasher, but uh.
- Go ahead and take it away.
Pick No. 2.
- Well, I'm gonna have to go with my former, well, I guess
current, still current, he did chirp me about being cheap cuz
I walked out on the bill one time, but that's nor here nor there.
Local Arizona kid.
He's going to his fourth All-Star Game.
He's got 10 goals in his last eight road games.
So he can't just get it done at home.
He gets it done on the road.
Uh, his sixth season as a Maple Leaf, 25 tucks each of those seasons
Auston Matthews, and a little dedication to Auston with a stash. Pablo!
Welcome to the lineup.
Woo-wee!
- I like that pick, Biz, I like that pick. Ah, I thought
about taking him No. 1, it was definitely a toss up.
That's a good one though.
You can't go wrong with that.
- And he's also getting the C on my squad,
OK?
I'm taking a right off of my, uh, my chest here and I'm giving it to him.
All right, you left the combo alive. Draisaitl,
he's gonna be playing with some angry.
He's gonna be playing with some fire after the interview that went down today.
Uh, we're going to be taking Draisaitl, putting
him and McDavid on line No. 1 here.
Is it my turn now?
You got your, your guy written down? Huberdeau.
- I do have him written down.
We went from the most, uh, Barkov being the most underrated player in
the league to Huberdeau. He's leading the league in assists by three.
I think he's got 38 on the year and who's gonna feed the
puck to one of the nastiest goal-scorers on the planet, Matthews?
The best passer.
So huge rookie mistake by you
Huby, and we're on nickname basis by the way, Huby.
- Yeah, I figured you would be.
I figured it would be, that's a tough one to spell as well.
- And he's got the assistant captaincy, as well.
His, uh, his agent Allan Walsh will probably be giving it to you
on Twitter for not picking him too and giving them the snub there.
- Listen, we're not going to be intimidated by
any agents here, Biz. We're all business,
all right?
So you gotta, you got Huby in there.
Uh, now the thing is, do I, do I want to focus on the D this early on?
There, I think there's a clear No. 1 defenseman in this draft and I, you
know what? He may as well be a Forward, we're taking the elite edge machine.
The guy that only scores nasty goals.
Cale Makar, toss 'em in that first-line D.
- I mean, I can't, I can't deny that pick. He's, uh, to me he's probably
the most impressive defenseman since Paul Coffey came around.
Now, I wasn't really around for much of Paul Coffey's
career cuz I was so young and, and wasn't really able
to absorb it and give it the credit that it deserves.
But Rick Tocchet told me a lot of similarities
in the way he moves up and down the ice.
So I can't fault you for that one.
Speaking of snubs, this next guy, I, the fact that he wasn't, uh, or
it had to go to the last man standing and for him to get voted in, uh,
he's gonna be coming into this All-Star Game, extremely motivated.
Uh let's hope he keeps it on the rails,
unlike Playoffs.
Uh, this is actually going to be his first All-Star Game, shockingly.
He's fifth in league scoring right now.
That's why I'm shocked that he was snubbed to begin with.
And, and, not to boot, it's a contract year and we
all know how much the moolah motivates guys.
- Yup
Welcome to the squad, Nazem Kadri! Woo-wee!
- I love it, dude.
There was nothing more hype than when he buried that
shootout winner with the announcer yelling about him
heading to Vegas, and then him actually getting voted in.
You just, you can't write a better story than that one.
- I'll give him an "A" too.
No, it was great.
And, uh, he plays with an edge too.
So keep your, tell your guys to keep their heads up out there.
- All right, Biz. I, uh, I'm at a loss of words as to
how this player is still available in the draft.
Probably the funniest guy in the league.
Uh, last time when there was an NHL All-Star
draft, this guy was begging to be picked last.
He's not getting picked last today.
We are taking Alexander Ovechkin, sitting him in that left circle
and, uh, guaranteeing at least a hat trick game out of him.
- He's an electric factory.
I don't blame that pick going back to a few All-Star Games ago. And a little
fun fact for you people at home, I believe he's going to be leading the
way with his eighth nod for everybody involved in this All-Star Game.
Twenty guys, it's their first time. But I forget which one it was.
It might've been the All-Star Game in Montreal at the Bell
Centre where he put the cowboy hat on and he electrified the crowd.
- [Laughing]
- So this guy, I don't blame you for that pick.
So I wish I could smack-talk you, but I can't.
This pick for me might come out a little bit off the board, but
in this type of format, you need also forwards being responsible
cuz there aren't many defensemen. And I can't think of a better
200-foot forward in the National Hockey League than Mark Stone.
OK.
Always up for the Selke.
He can contribute on offense.
He's gonna be great in the locker room.
He's used to that chaotic environment.
If I said that properly—chaotic—and it's at home for him.
- Is this his first All-Star as well?
- Mine? No, I usually -
- No, Mark's. No, Stoner. Oh, yeah, you.
- I just thought you were bringing up the fact that I was a two-time
ECHL All-Star in the minors, so I just must have crossed my mind there.
- We will move on.
Again, I mean, we're talking electric guys, I think
with this All-Star Game, I mean, you got Stoner there.
It's nice to get the guys that are in there first, right?
There's a little bit of hype, a little bit of buzz.
Ah, we're gonna take Kirill the Thrill.
Kaprizov. This guy has been flying out there.
Young guy, first time in an All-Star Game.
No shot he goes out there and does not put on a show for us.
- I mean, I just, I like the pick because Ovi's
gonna make him comfortable in the locker room, right?
You have that Russian connection.
- Yup.
- And as far as Kaprizov's concerned
he's used to the big stage as well.
He scored the sh— what was it?
The overtime winner in the gold-medal game against Germany in the last Olympics.
So they're probably gonna be trying to take it out on my squad,
given the fact that they can't go represent their countries this year.
So, I mean,
- That's a good point.
- All-Star Game, Olympics, I mean, competitive nature.
It's neck and neck.
- Yup.
I love it, man.
Hey, you're hyping up, you're hyping up my
picks for me, which I do greatly appreciate here.
- Yeah. Somebody must have handed you a sniffer and you woke up.
Listen, the All-Star Game, it's not all about
these fancy goals from the perimeter and dangling.
It's about getting to the blue paint and scoring the goals
that matter. Late in games, crunch time, when guys are
actually buckling down. And I want Joe Pavelski on my team.
Everybody thought he hit a certain age and he was gonna
fade off into the sunset and not compete anymore.
He's already got 20 tucks this year. And it's his fourth All-Star Game.
Experience.
- Wow.
You always need experience in the locker room.
And he's really good at everything, including golf.
He's a big hunter.
Pavs.
- Biz, I wanna be honest with you right now.
Your last few picks, you know, I'm looking at my list and
these guys are maybe not even cracking the top 20 on my list.
- Oh, that's cute. How many conference finals has Draisaitl and McDavid been to?
Just off the top of my head. How many?
- You're right. But listen, Pavelski is the type
of guy, he's scoring the greasy goals in there.
- He's a winner.
- And are we really getting greasy tips in front in All-Star Games?
No, we're looking for Michigans.
- Maybe your team won't be.
- We're looking for Zegras' baseball bats.
We're looking for, we're looking for some crazy stuff out here, Biz.
- Maybe your team won't be, but my team will.
One guy will.
You need a little bit of everything.
I mentioned that 200-foot game from Stone coming in.
Defensive pole checks on the way back.
You think Ovi's gonna be backchecking like Stone is?
He'll probably be hungover from bottle service from the night before.
- [Laughing]
- Stone's gonna be, he's gonna be home by 11 o'clock,
- You're right. You're right. Hey, I can't disagree.
in bed with the wife and kids.
And we're good to go.
- Yup.
I'm just going right down the list here.
You're literally letting me walk right down this thing.
Listen, we got one of the best defenders in the league.
The next Paul Coffey, as you claimed with Cale
Makar. We are going to take, ah, you know, maybe the next best,
right behind him, Adam Fox, New York Rangers. Speedy young guy.
These are guys, him and Cale both may as well be forwards. They're going out
there, can play some defense as well. It's the best of both worlds for me, Biz.
- You gotta remember, there's only one puck out there, right?
So you have all these guys who really, really like it.
So I don't know if you just knew that this one was gonna be played with one.
- Well, it looks like you're actually going deep into your notes.
I see you flipping pages.
- Yeah, I'm a little torn here on this next one.
And you know what?
I'mma lean back to loyalty.
Cuz that's what my team's about too.
And this is a guy, he'll be in his second All-Star Game
and a guy who I've seen make strides year over year
with the Arizona Coyotes organization [howling] Clayton Keller.
Great kid, needed to put a little weight on
in the offseason, came back 10 pounds stronger.
He's got that half a step that he needs, and that's
why he's been lighting up that Pacific Division.
OK.
Another probably surprise pick from
some of you, but as I said, loyalty matters on my team.
- Another off-the-board pick,
I got to say, uh, Biz.
That one is not even on my list,
you know, not even a consideration here.
- What? You didn't think I'd be picking a Coyote with my reverse retro on?
- I do love my boy Clayton Kelly, you know, and I know you wa-
What's that?
- I said, you didn't think I'd be
picking a Coyote with my reverse retro on?
- No, I knew you did!
I think you just wanted to, you just wanted to do the little howl thing.
- Smarten up.
- I mean, let's be honest here.
This one, you know, I'mma do my
first debatably off-the-board pick here.
This is a guy that buried five goals, a guy that
jumped from 30th to 10th place in league scoring overnight.
It just hasn't been done.
We're talking Timo Meier.
A little bit off the board. Maybe somebody that,
you know, the people didn't expect, but hey, listen,
he's hot right now.
He's a guy that I gotta take.
- And that San Jose team has been surprising a
lot of teams in that Pacific Division.
And I can't deny that one. You know what?
This one, another one is gonna be more of a loyalty pick.
And it's kind of a, more of an emotional
story for the people at home, Jack Campbell.
He was selected to his first All-Star Game.
I actually played with him in the American Hockey League, OK.
He was drafted in the first round by the Dallas Stars.
And I just think given the amount of pressure
being a first-rounder, he really lost his game.
Well, after getting traded over to the L.A. Kings organization, I had him on Ontario
in the minors with the Reign, and he was able to find his game again.
And he's battled all the way back.
He went up to L.A. and then ended up getting traded over, I believe with
Kyle Clifford, in a move that brought him to the Toronto Maple Leafs.
And now he's their starting goaltender.
He's having a Vezina-caliber season.
I'd say he's probably third in line right now.
And I couldn't be happier for you, Jack-O.
Welcome to the squad, Jack Campbell.
Soupy!
- Love that pick!
- See, we're gonna have so much chemistry in that locker room,
they won't even know what to do with it.
- Up next, for me, listen, we need a guy that's gonna
get the fans going a little bit, you know. We're in Vegas,
you know, there's a little bit of electricity in the air.
- Joe Thornton.
- Maybe. I mean, maybe some sticks need to be thrown into the stands,
some may say. I'm grabbing a guy that can
get some OT goals for us if it comes to that.
And that is my man Jack Hughes.
- He's like the TikTok generation hockey
player. All these new kids love him. Him, Zegras.
- Yeah
- I mean, you could throw Troy Terry in the mix there.
Do you know any TikTok dances?
- I—
- Is that how you do it?
- What do you call that one?
I was not ready for that.
- That's how you do the TikTok dances.
They're always like [dancing]
- That's like a little Renegade.
Yeah. I like that.
Let's go. Biz, do you have a TikTok account?
We gotta get you one.
- Somebody behind here is laughing.
Can we please have this person removed from the room?
I don't need those types of distractions in here and negativity.
I don't want any negativity in my locker room.
- Yeah. Biz, the people would love you on the Tok for sure.
Let's get that rolling here.
- I'm not, no, I have too many things going on.
Like dumbing you in this draft.
- Yet, you somehow had time to put some yarn on a board but...
- So I haven't drafted a defenseman yet, and you're
going to think, 'Oh, this one's off the board too.'
Who's going to play actual defense,
other than the guys that I said are going
to have to share a puck on your back end?
Pelech for the New York Islanders, as defensive as
they come, always a guaranteed clean, breakout pass.
He's not going to be pinching when he doesn't need to
cuz he's got the rest of the guys to provide the offense.
And he always gets pucks through when he gets 'em at the point.
And who's going to be there in front of the net tippin' it in?
Joe Pavelski. Already planned it out in my brain.
Keep the change, baby.
Woowee!
- I mean, that's an interesting pick.
I know, listen—you're maybe more of a bit more old school than me.
You like these stay-at-home defenders.
I went with the guys that, uh, they'll just be
rushing up the ice, coast-to-coast.
So I can respect that pick.
- You guys are gonna be pissing blood by the end of this game.
- You'll be pissing blood.
- Yup.
- 'Kay, well, if you're gonna
go that route, uh, well actually, you know what?
It's probably time for me to pick a goaltender.
I probably should get that off the board.
So you've taken Vasy and Campbell away from me. Both very solid picks.
I am gonna go with the red-hot Carolina Hurricanes.
We're gonna get our boy Freddie Andersen into the mix.
- That sucks.
Cuz I woulda liked him too, for the
connection with Auston Matthews, but a great goalie.
- You were going to go with the, uh, probably-never-done-before
three-goalie pick for your team if it came to it.
- Well, some of the guys you have—my goalies'll
be contributing more, at least on the backend.
- Interesting.
- Um, all right. Pick's in.
Um, we actually just interviewed him for our podcast and, uh, a kid that
not only did Joe Sakic when he was growin' up, say, "I think this guy's got a
bright future in the National Hockey League," saw it at that young of an age.
And then Paul Kariya, also with the same organization, said, "I think this kid's
got somethin' special," and he's having a breakout season with the Anaheim Ducks.
Troy Terry, another guy who was last man in.
I just think that they're gonna be coming in with a chip on their shoulder.
And I don't need that many guys playing that hardcore
defense, cuz I talked about the 200-foot game there.
So Troy Terry, one of the more undercover, pass, good passers in the league, too.
- Troy Terry.
Yeah. Man, him on that streak was just something special to watch.
He's made Anaheim, uh, you know, somethin' to turn into.
Him, Milano and Zegras all going at it.
I do actually really like that.
- And we talk about rising to the occasion.
If you go back to 2017, he was a guy who had three, uh, shootouts,
in that semifinal game against Russia at the World Juniors.
He ends up advancing them to the finals against Canada, and
he had a big game in the finals. Ends up winning a gold medal.
Three months later, after coming back from
injury at Denver, wins a national championship.
So we talkin' about a guy with a championship pedigree, and
then after getting sent down to the minors in Anaheim
in San Diego, ended up becoming an All-Star in the minors.
So this guy has got it done anywhere he's gone, Nasher. Anywhere he's gone.
- I love it.
So it is, uh, up to me for the last pick here.
And, uh, it is a goaltender for me, of course.
Gotta finish up the goaltending squad.
I'm gonna to pick a—listen.
This is a guy,—I'm going to tell you Biz, he
is probably the best NHL gamer in the NHL.
That is Thatcher Demko.
This guy is a man on the sticks.
He has beaten me before and, uh, if he could beat me
in CHEL, I'm going to get him on my all-star squad.
So we'll toss him in there.
All right Biz, let's bring it all together here.
First. I'll give you my rundown.
We have McDavid.
We have Draisaitl together.
We've got Cale on defense.
Line two: Ovi, Kirill the Thrill—the Russian connection—with
Adam Fox at D. Uh, that third line, we got Meier and Hughes-y.
In net, we've got Freddie Andersen and Demko.
This lineup, I mean—this is the picture-perfect lineup, Biz.
What've you got?
- The diversity.
I got a little bit of everything, buddy.
I'm gonna sprinkle—
I'm making a nice little winning stew.
All right.
Let's take a look.
We got Pablo wearin' the C, as he was already given from the National
Hockey League, but I'm gonna give it to him, too. That's how much I
trust his goal-scoring ability. And Huby—best passer in the league who's
gonna play with Pablo, the guy who's gonna put the bread in his basket?
Kadri, of course. He's coming in lethal.
He's pissed about getting snubbed originally.
He's back in.
Stoner, great 200-foot game. Pavs, greasy in front of the net.
He's gonna get us the garbage goals.
We talked about the loyalty with Kels. Defensive defenseman,
which I don't even think you came close to sniffing.
And then we finish it off with the wild card,
Troy Terry. And in net, the best goalie on the planet the last two, three
seasons, Andrei Vasilevskiy, and then the rock behind him, the good team guy,
the guy, if things aren't going well, can step in between the pipes for them.
And if things are going well, he'll be there to rub your back.
He'll be there to drive your kids to school and do
whatever it is, what it takes to win for the squad.
So ladies and gentlemen, you know who won this one.
It is over.
-  Now there is one last surprise addition,
uh, that we did not tell you beforehand.
And because you went first in the draft, I actually do get the first pick.
So we are going to do our snubs.
We're talking not last man in. We're talking not
on an All-Star Team. Players added to your team.
One additional roster spot has been added in.
And I'm going to tell you my pick off the rip, you're not gonna get to pick him.
- I already know who it is
- Who is it?
- It's Brad Marchand.
- It is not. But, listen, did you actually think it was Brad?
Cuz I mean, I, you know who I am, right?
You know what I'm looking for?
We're looking for content, and the king of content in the NHL right
now, none other and Trevor Zegras will officially be joining the squad.
- What?!
What?!
- Get your content, Biz.
- Over Brad Marchand?
Did you not hear him mic'd up on TNT dropping S-bombs?
And then on top of that, getting the trey-way hat trick against his former
rival the Montreal Canadiens, but they should be relegated to the AHL.
That's how bad they are.
I got Brad Marchand.
Not only was he snubbed, he should have been the first All-Star in there.
Cuz he is a content factory.
You must have lost your mind, Nasher.
- Has Brad Marchand ever flipped the puck over the net and had it batted in?
- Whoop de doo!
Has Zegras ever won an NHL playoff game?
- I mean, it is his rookie year.
Who's, who's to say?
- I got the Rat King, Brad Marchand.
I respect your pick.
And I respect the way that Trevor Zegras—one of
those TikTok players—is reinventing the wheel.
I respect that, and I'm sure the fans are gonna love it,
but this is all about, oowa-oowa-ooo, W's buddy, bling, bling, bling.
- OK. Honestly, Biz.
I think it might be, like, I think it might be a double digit defeat for you.
Like looking at the list.
I mean, I went straight down my list.
You were going the opposite direction of my list,
starting down in the twenties and working your way up.
- Yeah.
- So we're in a pretty good spot I think here.
-  Yeah.
Well, I think you should shut your mouth.
- [Laughing].
- Oh, you're laughing?
You think I'm kidding?
We'll see ya, we'll see ya in the All-Star Game there, bud, in Vegas,
- Alright, Biz. I will.
- I'll see you in Vegas.
And bring some cash with ya, bring a duffel bag full of cash and put it on the line.
Put your money where your mouth is!
- Hey Biz, I will. Listen, I want every single person watching this,
I want you to reply right now: Who has the better team?
I'm not gonna let this guy get up in my face and yell at me.
- You're going to be pissing blood, buddy.
- This is for the fans, Biz!
- Just like the rest of your squad.
You're going to be pissing blood.
- They're the ones…
- They are the ones that decide, all right?
Take your cowboy hat. Yeah, leave, all right?
- You want a piece of me?!
- Um, I'm a little intimidated.
- I'm a little intimidated here now.
- I gotta get out of here, uh Biz, it's been a pleasure.
Uh, good, good hanging out.
And uh, we'll see you guys next time.
Peace.